allez on va terminer avec le patron avec
le boss avec le prince de l'audience et
de l'audimat avec cyril hanouna qui a
fait une déclaration hier fonds pf un
personnel on me fait beaucoup rire
il a eu des propos assez assez sévère et
ma foi assez juste sur le fait que tf1
avait tendance à venir chercher des gens
sur ces 8 regardez les images
julien l'égard des femmes mettez la télé
parce que là vous allez en prendre plein
la gueule
je vous rappelle les faits la gare s'il
était sur tf1 du jour au lendemain tf1
et non plus appeler du tout il fait un
million 4e qui sait qu'il appelle comme
une fleur aujourd'hui dès qu'on se met
quelqu'un l'antenne ils le veulent
c'est quand même ouf non mais les gars
et il ya un peu d'idées franchement en
fait votre vie on a un et camille combal
ici ils le veulent
on a amené burner quiz ils le veulent de
vous dire la vérité de leurs mots si
l'on appelle s'ils le voulaient détruire
des trucs et pour danse avec les stars
franchement les mecs arrêtez pas sur la
tendance à venir
alors j'aime pas j'aime pas pour causer
pourquoi vous n'aimez pas recueillir à
ce que je comprends attend des excuses
et moi c'est moi oui bonjour à mon
talent et vous trompez pas très bien je
vais en parler
c'était une blague
je comprends la frustration de série
laisse à la colère qu'il est qu'il
montre mais à bref je crois alors je
pense qu'il n'est pas du tout frustré
oui non mais ça ça sa frustration
peut-être que ce n'est pas le bon terme
que j'ai adopté en tout cas je comprends
ce qu'ils expriment
mais je trouve que c'est le jeu des
médias alors c'est déplorable de voir
que tf1 n'a pas d'imagination
mais d'une certaine manière cyril du
pâtis du fait qu'il a de bonnes idées et
que d'autres ont envie de piocher dans
les idées qu'il a et puis pour ce qui
est de la gaffe je les veux ici je les
ai vus dans les grandes gueules sur rmc
j'ai eu l'impression que avant même le
succès de son émission il avait exprimé
l' envie d'être libre et pas forcément
d'être assigné à une chaîne particulière
donc c'est le jeu des médias et pour moi
cette bonne guerre alors vu j'estime
beaucoup rokhaya mais là je suis en
total c'est pas le jeu des médias c'est
de l'anti moral c c c est moi c'est du
business
ah non mais là c'est contre les lois du
business c'est de là je trouve que
d'immenses pans de la panne ou alors
c'est non sincère c'est dégueulasse
qu'ils ont fait le complice
je comprends qu'il soit énervé il a bien
raison les énerver un peu le principe du
mercato chaque année et qu'il appelle
avant pas le lendemain c d opportunisme
l'arrêté va jamais d'accord ces moyens
nous dit ça parce que vous avez bossé à
tf1 et que peut-être vous les robots
c'est pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
je suis très bien non edward m ouais
ouais non mais moi je trouve que c'est
je trouve que c'est surtout les méthodes
qui sont un petit peu reproché quoi je
pense que tu peux appeler enfin
apparaître entre patrons de chaînes
voilà et puis tu dis bah tiens fois que
j'ai fois que j'ai un entretien avec un
des collègues
voilà ce que je pense qu'en plus un jour
après alors ça se passe pas comme ça
mais c'est vrai que bon je sais je suis
pas encore de vous l'expliquer alors oui
vous aimez bien oui moi j'aime mais
parce qu'en fait ils dès qu'ils ont vu
qu'il a cartonné dès lors appelé ssige
pape est retourné je pense pas qu'ils
voient là alors s'il n'avait pas
cartonné il n'aurait pas appelé du tout
ça sans aucun doute due sur le principe
je sais c'est sûr évident ne vais pas
vous tito moi non moi j'aime bien le
principe de ce que fait cyril depuis des
années de faire participer les
téléspectateurs et spectateurs avec les
voilà les coulisses des médias et de
dire ce qu'ils pensent
mais après je rejoins complètement
recréé à c'est quand même voilà les les
le jeu du métier depuis des années même
danse donné 6 pin c'est par exemple ce
qu'a voulu crier cyril c7 ce principe de
d'oublier les gens pendant huit années
les poussines et enfin celles qui se
mouillent aujourd'hui pour récupérer des
animateurs que plus personne ne veut il
les prend parce qu'ils les aiment avoir
menti en bas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
des gens comme moi par exemple si nos
fans de ces deux mâles les aime
profondément est parti les admiratif de
leur carrière c'est le seul qui se
mouillent allait mettre à l'antenne et
ça fout les boules et sa mémoire on va
les [ __ ] mon week-end